le suisse fois supérieure avec réalité
j'ai leur argent les attendent
d'accord mais de voir en se sachant que
monsieur mercadé et banquiers as de la
tromperie il gère l'insistance de ses
créanciers
mais cette fois il est acculé c'est le
monde des affaires qui est en train de
naître
à ce moment là et le monde des affaires
des aphorismes et surtout moi s'il ya
beaucoup dans cette pièce c'est toute la
dimension qui est très liée à à
l'excitation du jeu en fait le faiseur
que joue brunck et lison personnages de
ce mercato donc s'appelle les faiseurs
sont en outre ça mais c'était un grand
joueur
addictif ça parle de l'entrée est ce
qu'on peut avoir sur les autres
adapté par évelyne l'homme est mis en
scène par robin renucci le directeur des
tréteaux de france le faiseur ces deux
heures d'une pièce millimétré et sans
temps mort une comédie grinçante ou la
composition d'acteur prend toute son
ampleur
tu comédie particulière parce que elle
travaille sur plusieurs genres qui à la
fois du burlesque du mélodrame da
comédie caractères la comédie de
situation presque du masque cirque on
est extrêmement maquillé comme comme des
masques avec des perruques très
particulière des costumes sont très
marquées qui sont très dans le style
dallas daumier
spéculation tromperies mensonges et
manipulations plus d'un siècle nous
séparent de l'écriture et pourtant la
pièce semble intemporel
il ya énormément de matière dans le
texte de balzac qui est très riche qui
est vraiment extraordinaire il faut
imaginer qu'il a écrit en 1840 et que
c'est un texte qui est complètement
moderne
quand il ya eu la ferme addow là il ya
quelques années le faiseur ils ont
ressorti et est marqué la ferme à
d'offres écrites par balzac en 1840
c'est pour dire comme il était vraiment
visionnaire avec de l'énergie et du
rocambolesque monsieur mercadé n'a pas
fini de nous interroger sur un problème
de société actuels années d'autres c'est
lui